Robert E.
Lee.
Today,
the mere mention of his name was enough to arouse passionate debate in his time.
He was loved and respected by both the confederate army and the southern people.
Curiously,
following the civil war,
this high admiration carried over to include the people of the north and Lee
became a cherished figure for all Americans during the war.
When Abraham Lincoln looked at a picture of Lee,
he remarked that a man with such compassionate countenance had to be a good man,
but the water which he devoted his every fiber broken,
if not in spirit,
certainly in body.
And he was only to outlive the conflicts.
By five years into these biographics,
we discover the man who was Robert E.
Lee.
Okay.
Robert E.
Lee was born on January the 19th 1807 at Stratford hall plantation in
Westmoreland County,
Virginia.
His father,
they wealthy Virginia Aristocrat,
been a hero during the American revolution,
a series of bad investments,
left light horse,
Harry penniless,
and he fled Virginia and his family never to return.
I think it was raised by his mother,
uh,
prouds and educated woman.
She was to see the test son was not to be deprived of a proper upbringing
because he was fatherless and she made sure that he was well educated in the
arts languages and philosophy.
Young Robert Secures an appointment to the United States Military Academy at
West Point in 1825 and see graduated second in his class.
He immediately began his career in the United States army.
They distinguished himself in the Mexican war when he served as a member of
staff for fellow Virginia in general,
Winfield Scott as a captain,
[inaudible] was responsible for several courageous personal reconnaissance
missions,
which produced intelligence that led to American victories.
During this period,
the military had no medals for bravery,
so officers were given brevet promotions for brave deeds during warfare APP.
Captain only received three of these,
prevents during the Mexican war to me,
Jeb to lieutenant colonel and finally to Carnal sculpt describes me as the very
best soldier I ever saw in the fields and they progress through a series of
military assignments in the peacetime army and was in command of the first
cavalry in Texas at the beginning of the civil war league or caught up early in
the political term.
All it was about to engulf the nation while he was on leave.
From his position in Texas,
John Brown attacker to the armor is Harper's ferry and events that clearly set
the nation on the road to walk.
President Buchanan calls on leads take command of a small federal force that
would be responsible for bringing the situation under control,
Lee and a future subordinate.
He was also on leave.
Jaeb Stewart took command of a small group of marines and it's captured the
insurgents along with brown as a nation began to fracture bleed like most of his
contemporaries in the army was placed in a difficult situation as it became
obvious that the southern states plan to defend themselves with arms general.
Winfield,
Scott,
the aging patriarch of the army.
Aj Lincoln,
too.
Awfully commander of the army.
Learning of this offer at least struggles with the definition of duty does it
meant everything to him as an officer in the United States army.
Yeah.
On April the 19th 1861 after Virginia had quit the union,
Robert E.
Lee face the most difficult decision of his life.
It's kept him up all night pacing the wooden floor and the visit Arlington
Mansion.
Lee's daughter Mary courteously recalls this that night.
Arlington was like a place where a death,
a ACAT.
The death in question was the end of a brilliant military Korea.
Lee's wife,
Mary,
they to wrote,
my husband's has wept tears of blood over this terrible war,
but as a man of honor and does a Virginian,
he must follow the destiny of his State is what was the severest struggle of his
life?
Do you resign a commission he had held for 30 years to accept the command would
undoubtedly mean fighting against his native Virginia and the south.
Something that he simply couldn't bring himself to do.
Resignation from the army was also a difficult choice to make and it does.
He wrestled with his decision.
He was attended by the prospects of bloodshed on either side.
Finally,
he decided to resign his commission in the army and attempt to to avoid service
with either side in the forthcoming conflict,
Lee himself wrote with all my devotion to the union and the feeling of loyalty
and duty of an American citizen,
I have not been able to make up my mind to raise my hand against my relatives,
my children,
my home.
I have that for resigned my commission in the army except in the defense of my
native state.
I hope to never draw my sword again.
This statements was to prove to be prophetic.
On Monday,
they bought the 22nd 1861 Lee left his home at Arlington,
never to return within two weeks,
union troops,
they occupied to south Mary Hams there for girls.
They were vagabonds of war.
His three sons were soldiers in gray.
While Lee was in Richmond planning the defense of Virginia.
The general belief among politicians in the south was that the war would be
short,
but Lee,
he believed otherwise he status.
If it comes to a conflict of arms,
the war will last at least four years.
Northern politicians do not appreciate the determination and pluck of the south
and southern politicians do not appreciate the numbers,
resources,
and it's patient.
Perseverance of the north.
Both sides forgets we are all Americans.
I foresee that the country will have to pass through a terrible ordeal,
a necessary expiation perhaps for our national sins.
Okay.
During the early days of the warrior,
it became apparent to me that the south would fight a defensive war and that is
beloved Virginia would become the major battlefield of that war.
He accepted a commission as a commander of Virginia.
His troops,
and we're seeing commission does a brigadier general in the confederate army.
He remains in relativity obscure positions during the first year of the war as
he gained his earliest experiences in the civil war in the mountainous region of
western Virginia.
Yeah.
The poor weather combines with the political infighting between two of
Virginia's former governors.
Now generals resulted in disastrous military failures for the confederacy.
Lee,
he was attacked in southern newspapers,
is evacuating Leeann's granny leaves his hand runs,
isn't ubid tens gray during the tension filled bouncing campaigns please.
Next assignment.
It was on the Carolina Sea coast where he was responsible for building defenses
to prevents launch scale union army attacks from the seat.
He placed his strong defensive positions upstream where shallow rivers could not
be easily navigated by the union.
Navy.
Lee's ability as a military engineer was proved by the fact that his defenses
will have to last for much of the war.
He was also nicknames the king of spades because of the construction work that
he managed.
His detractors.
However,
what seems to realize their mistake and misjudging this aggressive officer,
what is West Point classmates and Joseph [inaudible] Johnson was severely
wounded at the battle of seven pines.
In June of 1862 linguists placed in commands of what would soon become the
legendary army of Northern Virginia as union general George Mcclellan advanced
towards the new confederate capital Lee auditors' mandate to begin digging
defenses for Richmond's giving new credence to one of his nicknames,
but he soon was to demonstrate the audacious side of his military personality.
Leah initiated the seven days campaign on June the 25th 1862 and he had soon it
pushed the union army from the outskirts of Richmond.
By August 29th he and his army were positioned to do battle as Manassas,
Virginia,
where he defeated the Union army for a second time before invading Maryland's.
This new commands of the confederate army had completely changed the military
situation.
In only a few weeks.
In June,
the entire union army had been poised to attack Richmond's,
but by September he was in a position from which you could threaten Washington,
DC.
Lee's army fought to a stalemate at the battle of Antietam and on September the
17th and withdrew to the southern side of the potter Mac in December,
but he was able to conclude the 1862 campaign with a major victory of Ambrose
Burnside's Union forces at Fredericksburg,
Virginia,
sending the northern army reeling back to their basis now Washington Lee and
this hard marching subordinate,
stonewall Jackson were able to defeat a larger union army under Joseph Hooker at
Chancellorsville in the first campaign of 1863 but the victory was costly.
Jackson was fatally wounded by his own men while conducting a personal
recognizance of the enemy's lines.
This was actually a common feature of good confederate commanders.
They would actually conduct that own recognizance during a lull in the battle
viewed as unnecessary bravado by some historians.
This was actually a key to the successful operations of the confederate
commanders and Lee himself frequently under Tareq of these hazardous operations.
Favorite sounds from a personal battlefield reconnaissance.
That second Manassas with a mark on his face where a sharp shooters,
bullets at grace,
Devon lease immediate reactions of the death of his most trusted officer was
that it was God's wealth and the Lord would raise someone else up to Jackson's
place and that's hope.
However,
he was mistaken,
Lee would just have to do the best he could by himself.
At Chancellorsville.
These cemented his reputation as a brilliant brilliance battlefield commander.
It was a battle that seemingly on paper he could not win,
outnumbered this two to one.
He's still divided his army in half in the face of the enemy.
He won the battle in spectacular fashion and it was undoubtedly has most famous
victory.
The victory of Chancellorsville cleared the way for another confederate invasion
of the north confusion within the Union army combined with the losses of the
earlier basil gave,
leave the opportunity.
He longed for a chance to destroy the union army in a classic and Napoleonic
battle that would end the civil war.
This was a high risk operation,
but Lee placed great faith in the ability of his army of northern Virginia and
to get his bag.
This is where he would attempt to do it again.
Okay.
In June of 1863 lead boldly moved his army of nearly 60,000 men into union
territory.
His plan was to destroy as many military posts does he could in Maryland and
Pennsylvania.
While the Union army was forced to defend Washington DC,
a key target Swisscom curtain just outside of Harrisburg,
Pennsylvania.
This was the largest military supply depot in the north.
I think his main aim was not to defeat to the union army militarily,
but to bring the water and ends politically.
He believed that a massive defeat in the north would encourage people to lose
faith in the warm and demand it's cents.
However,
as the confederate forces move north,
a skirmish erupted in Gettysburg,
Pennsylvania between opposing cavalry units,
legal word of the skirmish and were startled to be informed.
There's a major union force was closing it on Guettas back.
Instead of sending a cavalry reconnaissance force to confirm the report,
he sent his entire army to mobilize.
This is something that history would record as a colossal mistake.
The audit,
all of his forces to converge at cash down that small village seven miles from
gutters back.
That's the 60,000 confederates port.
In around 3000 union soldiers took position on Macpherson Ridge.
These men trying to hold off the onslaught of rebel soldiers until help arrived,
but reinforcements were miles away.
In Washington DC,
the union soldiers,
they were forced to withdraw southeast on the cemetery Ridge,
a range of hills on the outskirts of Gettysburg that forms the shape of a fish
hook.
This position provided an extremely strong defensive advantage.
Lee immediately saw the danger in the strength of the union position,
but because of his numerical superiority,
he believed that the enemy was vulnerable.
However,
union forces sooner arrived and strengthens their defensive position.
Though it was nowhere near Lee's bass campaign,
much of what happened to get his bag,
we're still remarkable from a southern perspective,
Lee was our numbers ends without much of his cavalry.
The cavalry was used largely for reconnaissance in order to find the enemy and
establish his size and strength.
But Lee's calvary regiments were in the process of reading the entire union army
rather than gathering information and screening the flanks of Lee's army,
and he was also without his most trusted officer at general,
Thomas Stonewall Jackson,
who had been killed at Chancellorsville six weeks earlier,
still let you failed to adjust your strategy to the situation on the grounds he
refused to retreat even when the situation was clearly hopeless.
After three days of terrible fighting and unprecedented losses,
the confederates were forced to withdraw from the fields and to make a hasty
retreat from the northern territory.
As the survivors of the disastrous attack that history remembers,
his pickets challenge came fleeing back to the southern position,
the general road among the men trying to console them and admitting that it was
all his faults.
In later reflection,
they admitted that he had simply asked too much of his men at Gettysburg.
He wrote,
no blame can be attached to the army for its failure to accomplish what was
projected by me.
I am alone to blame.
Gettysburg was Lee's greatest wartime disappointments in its way.
He tended his resignation as you confederate President Jefferson Davis rising.
Mr President.
No one is more than myself and my inability for the duties of my position.
I cannot even accomplish what I myself desire.
How can I fulfill the expectations of others?
In addition,
I sensibly feel v growing failure of my bodily strength.
This was no idle self pitying,
the civil war,
and in particular the battle of Gettysburg Broccoli.
Physically.
There is good evidence that to just before the Bassel he actually had a heart
attack.
Still.
Davis refused to accept his resignation knowing that the man was irreplaceable.
Following Gettysburg,
the retreated across the potter Mac never to return to the north again.
The following spring,
a new Yankee general came to the fields to fight leap.
His name was Ulysses Simpson grants.
Finally,
the North had founds a worthy contender for the great confederate general.
Unlike many of his predecessors,
groms was not covered by lead.
Both men underestimated each other,
seemed discovering that their opponents was different from anyone else that had
ever been up against.
Immediately upon taking commands at grant issued the following commands do
general needs,
commander of the army of the potter Mac Lee's army will be your objective points
wherever ligos there you will go.
Also,
grants relentlessly pursued Lee from the wilderness to Spotsylvania and then to
cold harbor wearing terrible slaughter took place throughout the bloody campaign
and despite heavy losses,
Lee Galleon Lee led his army on May the sixth 1864 is his line was wavering.
He himself rode to the front and demanded that his men stand their ground on the
very dangerous circumstances.
After June,
1864 Lee's army of northern Virginia had been pushed back to the defenses of
Richmond's and back.
Effectively.
Grants had taken him out of the war,
unable to maneuver and know where to go or they could do now was wait and to
react as grant circling around him,
access with his army besieged and pin down the knew that the end was in sight.
Lee's anguish while being hemmed up at Petersburg was heightens with the news
that his home in Arlington had been confiscated by the union governments having
been seized for unpaid taxes.
It was quickly converted into a large soldiers' cemetery.
Orders were given for the graves to be placed as close to the house as possible
so that it could never be used again as a private dwelling.
However,
the cruelest bro,
but it was yet to come through the winter of 1864 Lee's army lacked forage
rations and supplies somehow managed to retain their fighting spirit,
but even that's was to disappear in April of 1865 with his men that are near
starvation point,
Lee led his bedraggled army to Appomattox courthouse in Virginia following a
last desperate flight from Richmond and it was there that Lee surrendered his
army and ended the civil war.
The correspondence between grants and lead during those closing hours of the war
is enlightening.
On April the seventh grants sent the following message to leave general.
The results of the last week must convince you of the hopelessness of further
resistance in this struggle.
I regarded it as my duty to shift from myself the responsibility of any further
a fusion of blood by asking of you the surrender of the army of northern
Virginia.
Very respectfully.
You s grants,
Lee's reply.
It came swiftly.
General grants though not entertaining the option you express on the
hopelessness of further resistance on the part of the army of northern Virginia.
I reciprocate your desire to avoid useless a fusion of bloods and therefore ask
the terms you will offer in condition if it's surrender.
Very respectfully.
Robert E.
Lee.
On the morning of April the ninth Lee put on his best uniform and went to the
home of Wilmer Mclean where he met general grant.
The two men contrasted sharply Lee six feet high,
ends with faultless form and dress grants.
Five foot seven mud splatters as in a rumpled private,
so uniform the terms of Sorento.
While unexpectedly generous without demand for punishment,
the confederate army was allowed to go home on the provision that they would
never take up arms again against the federal governments.
Many historians believed that it was a measure of grants respectfully,
that he handled the terms the way he did.
As he exited the Mclean House,
Lee was chaired by the confederates and saluted by the union troops,
asked officer of the Union to remove his hat and saluted.
Lee was grants.
Yeah.
After the war,
he became president,
so of Washington College in Lexington,
Virginia.
During those years,
he also found time to write his memoir and in it he stated the following,
I did only what my duty demanded.
I could have taken no other course without dishonor,
and if at all were to be done over again,
I should act in precisely the same manner.
He dedicated his last years to education.
On September the 28th 1870 he went to a school meeting on the way home and he
caught a Kohl's.
14 days later,
he died.
The huge funeral service at Lexington was attended by thousands of Americans
from both the north and the south.
So I really hope you found that biography.
Interesting.
If you did these,
do hit that thumbs up button below and don't forget to subscribe.
Brand new videos every Monday and Thursday.
Also,
who would you like to see on biographics?
You can go to our companion website,
biographics.org click on the bio votes in the bar at the top ends.
We have a voting system set up there so we can make the biographies that you
guys want to see and as always,
thank you for watching.